Simplifica la siguiente expresión
4x cuadrada "y" -3xy más 25
y a todo eso le vamos a restar 9y cuadrada "x" más 7xy -20
¿Muy bien? Esto es exactamente lo mismo que restar individualmente cada uno de estos términos, o bien que distribuir el signo menos,
o bien que pensarlo como un -1 y multiplicar cada uno de los términos. Todo eso es exactamente lo mismo
entonces, vamos a hacer eso. Primero vamos a reescribir el lado izquierdo así
igualito, por que ahí no hay ningún signo menos que nos esté dando lata, 4x cuadrada  "y" - 3xy
más 25, más 25 y ahora sí vamos a distribuir este signo menos en color naranja,
y a ver - por 9y cuadrada "x" este con éste nos quedaría
- 9y cuadrada "x", ahora este menos con este 7xy
pues simplemente hace que el 7xy tenga signo menos, -7xy
y finalmente este menos con este - 20 pues pensando esto como un -1, -1  por -20 nos da
más 20 por que menos por menos es más, es este término de acá.
¿Ok? Entonces ya no tenemos paréntesis ya únicamente tenemos que sumar o restar los términos similares,
vamos a hacerlo. Déjame empezar con este término de acá lo voy a poner de color rojo
entonces 4x cuadrada "y",
tenemos otra cosa de la forma "x" cuadrada "y" en nuestra expresión pues éste no, este no, este no,
no únicamente tenemos este 4x cuadrada "y" entonces lo voy a copiar así 4x cuadrada "y"
igualito ¿Va? Ahora vamos con términos de la forma xy, como este de aquí. Lo voy a poner en color rosa.
Tenemos un -3xy ¿Hay otro? Si aquí hay otro, este es -7xy
si a -3xy le restamos 7xy si tenemos -3 cosas y nos quitan otras 7 entonces, nos quedan
-10xy ¿Va?.
- 3- 7 es -10. Ahora vamos con este 25, este 25 es un término constante.
Este término constante pues acá tiene otro compañero ¿Verdad? Este 20 también es constante entonces, tendríamos que hacer la suma
25 con 20 que es 45,
más 45 y finalmente nos queda este término de aquí, que voy a poner en color azul.
En color azul y este claramente ya no se puede juntar con nadie más, por que ya contamos a todos con todos,
y entonces nos queda -9y cuadrada "x"
Listo ya realizamos la resta y nos quedó 4x cuadrada "y" -10xy
más 45 -9y cuadrada "x".